et une question pour vous raphaël pythie
de delphes harry mata qui demandent
quelle aide est apportée aux africains
qui sont bloqués en ukraine justement je
voulais prendre à prendre à ce sujet
j'étais donc au centre le centre de
secours qui est un centre de secours au
niveau du poste médical poste-frontière
de medica qui est tenu par les
sauveteurs sans frontières qu'ils sont
israéliens qui ont mis en place un
dispositif d'accueil et de prise en
charge bien évidemment il vendait ils
ont bien vu que le traitement n'était
pas est identique entre les étrangers
d'origine africaine et autres
malheureusement et la population
ukrainienne qui sortaient les ukrainiens
les rejeter les empêcher de monter dans
les bus etc ils sont venus à pied ils
ont été bastonnés frappe etc ils ont été
pris en charge justement sur le plan
sanitaire par ces sauveteurs sans
frontières le comportement de la part
d'un certain nombre de populations qui
fuyait
rejeté tous les étrangers qui ensuite en
arrivant au poste frontière hanté mis
dans des centres de détention centre de
détention et non pas dans un centre
d'hébergement et il fallait que leur
consulat vienne les chercher et les
amène dans leur pays donc conclusion le
traitement des africains à une
différente africains et des autres
étrangers en particulier oui je t'ai que
la ligne téléphonique le dispositif
était mise en place tout de suite par le
ministère des affaires étrangères
craignant qu'ils aidaient exactement aux
étudiants d'origine étrangère pour
sortir je crois qu'au tout début il y
avait ces embuscades parce que les
ukrainiens normalement ils ont droit de
voyager sans visa et c'est pas le cas de
tous les pays africains et après bien
sûr dès que leurs gouvernements ont
réagi leur ambassade tout ça était
facilitée et moi je connais aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de bénévoles
ukrainiens qui ont aidé les étudiants
africaine de sortir donc là c'est y
avait des actions positives aussi